what were some of the recurring
questions you were trying to ask
yourself while writing echo I think the
the recurring question I wanted to ask
myself was why is this personal for the
main character the genre that I wanted
to work under which is the spy thriller
genre very well tread very very worn
there are not a lot of trails to be
blazed there so I wanted it to be a
portrait I started there I started okay
this needs to be very intimate about the
main character and why he needs to know
what he needs to know and so and it
expanded from there somatically to me
which was he needs to know where he came
from not because he has amnesia or
something like Jason Bourne but he needs
to know where he came from because he is
going to be a father and his wife is
pregnant in the film and she's very far
along but they're balancing their life
with the fact that he's a crab fisherman
so he's gone for months at a time and
one of the reasons why I wrote him as a
crab fisherman was I know a lot of
fishermen and they will tell you that
there are a lot of you know interesting
people on those boats there there are
nomads there are outlaws there are
people that are fugitives and there are
captains of those boats who make a
decision about whether or not they're
going to pay someone in cash or in check
and so forth
generally speaking the industry is very
aboveboard so I don't want to come
across as someone who's disparaging to
the fishing industry which is
extraordinary but there are there are
people you meet who you say man I really
wonder about his past
and I was in a bar and I was writing I
was expanding this character who is a
former assassin and I was talking to my
friend who's a former fisherman and we
were at a fishing bar so to speak and I
started to look around and I started to
see him in these faces I started to see
like he's this guy's running from
something and that guy's running from
something and I wanted that guy's done
time like hard time right and so
I went back and looked at some of the
research methods that Michael Mann used
for his first film thief and some of the
research he did for Miami Vice and for
LA crime story and for heat which is my
favorite film of all time and he really
talked to people who are criminals they
talked to people who are cops I talk to
people who are dealers and so forth so I
was like all right I'm really gonna the
questions I'm gonna ask myself are why
does he matter why would I believe this
why would he go from being a
professional high level killer who's
paid to do this and works for a
clandestine organization to working on a
fishing boat so I kept asking myself you
know how can we keep this grounded you
know how can we keep this story
believable what ended up happening was
in the script was the film became a love
story and I think some audience members
have really responded well to that you
know I think they really think the film
is beautiful I think some audience
members expected John wick for you know
they expected a smash action picture
with stunt sequences and it's not that
and in the marketing we tried to make it
more beautiful and in the way we
promised to deliver the film to the
audience we tried to talk about its love
story and the complications of that and
so the questions I kept asking myself
when I was writing it was if this man's
gonna be a father then he has to know
his beginning to and and if someone
found him right if he wants to live in
obscurity and if he wants to be a ghost
and have a quiet life if someone found
him a news truth what would he do what
would he do to protect that and and
that's where everything started because
the treatment later when I had was the
story of the film but that's not the
motivation for a character that's like
this happens and this happens and this
happens and this happens and then it
ends like this right and it was very
interesting because when I went to go
write the script to end
changed when I went to go right at the
relationship between who his father was
changed and the organization went from
being sort of a global question mark
Empire or organization like Tyrell
corporation in Blade Runner or Wallis
Corporation and Blade Runner 24 tonight
we're like well this is this ubiquitous
like evil Apple right and it changed
completely to like this very private
family-owned company that's protecting
its interests so everything became more
grounded and I kept asking myself how
can I make this more of a portrait of of
one man's life instead of making it
about like corporate espionage which it
does have in it as well why did you need
to tell this story it's like asking me
why I have to breathe I knew from doing
years of ads I knew from writing both in
Seattle and Los Angeles on New Zealand
that all of the energies of those
pursuits were pointing me towards making
a feature and crossing over so to speak
like crossing the line from ads to you
know doing from doing Sprint's to a
marathon and everything anybody tells
you about shooting a film about its
rigor and its sheer impossibility is
true from my experience it's true
and I remember the drive of we started
this now you have to finish it and the
feeling that we could you know we had
all the right people to make a
complicated very very layered story come
to life and then internally I had to
push myself as hard as I could ever like
it's like doing 200 commercials in a
month right
and and keeping a balance and a
discipline for the work and my visual
aesthetic and the cinematographer calls
me we are very close and he's and he
says he says you are the guardian of the
image and what that means is it's a very
high compliment but more importantly
than being a compliment what he means is
I'm looking at everything for every shot
for everything and I storyboard
everything I call every lens on every
shot and so I think I had to kind of
have this baptism by fire any of those
awesome phrases but it but it was also
climbing a mountain I've used that
metaphor a lot to the point of I'm sure
if some people watch this who know me
they'll be like I was talking about
mountains again but there are times I've
read a lot of books I've read a lot of
true story biographies about different
climbers and there are times they talk
about moving in a group getting to base
camp moving to this other camp moving to
this other elevation and then they talk
about like summiting or getting
somewhere where they climb in the dark
or they climb alone and that's why I had
to do it I had to I had to finish it and
I had to get to the top and there's
still no sense of satisfaction or pride
or any of that it's just it's like that
quiet feeling of you did it but it
doesn't feel good like it doesn't feel
like joyful you know it feels like it
feels like you're more obsessed than
ever to do it again
you